diese fahrt endet schon nach wenigen
metern im acker schwere sturmböen
schieben den bus im landkreis görlitz in
sachsen einfach von der glatten fahrbahn
ohne bergungsgerät gibt es hier kein
weiterkommen
in bayern haben rettungskräfte die ganze
nacht kräftig zu tun das blechdach einer
industriehalle im allgäu hat sich gelöst
und landet auf einem mehrfamilienhaus in
abensberg in niederbayern bereiten
umgestürzte bäume den helfern auch heute
noch viel arbeit
ich befürchte dass der verletzten
stürmer da kommt die nächsten stunden
noch einiges noch und jetzt will morgen
wird mich der wind nachlässt und es wird
normales wetter gibt dann den kehrt
wieder ruhe im einsatzgeschehen bei der
bahn läuft der verkehr wieder weitgehend
problemlos einige regionalverbindungen
bleiben unterbrochen
auch am münchner flughafen herrscht
wieder überwiegend normalbetrieb etwa 80
flüge fallen bisher aus teilweise sind
auch die maschine oder cruise nicht an
der stelle an der sie sein sollten das
sind halt da noch nachwehen von gestern
im norden drohen auch heute noch
sturmfluten in bremerhaven hat man sich
entsprechend vorbereitet und hofft dass
es gut geht auf den straßen machen den
verkehr zusätzlich heftige schneefälle
zu schaffen
insgesamt bleibt es also ziemlich
ungemütlich